this is going to be really kind of more of like a trial in progress uh very early days for this trial
uh these are my disclosures
so treatment of relapsed refractory uh mantle cell lymphoma is still a major unmet need
typically after frontline therapy with chemo immunotherapy patients would get covalent btk
inhibitors in the second line sitting here just for example is an abrutinib within a median pfs
of just under three years after that typically patients would go on to CAR-T cell for example
brexa cell or lysa cell however duration of response is limited with a pfs of about 15 months
so really durability of these subsequent lines of therapy are limited pure to brutinib is active in
relapsed refractory mantle cell lymphoma
as discussed on the left is the efficacy data from the bruin trial the overall response in
covalent btki pre-treated patients is about 57 percent in btki naive patients about 86 percent
uh and the pfs was quite short 7.4 months in the btk pre-treated patients and not reached in btki
naive however with quite short follow-up and infections are what we would expect with btk
inhibitors including um they're sorry adverse event
are what we expect in btk inhibitors including infectious neutropenia and others
blofitimab is also highly active for relapsed mantle cell lymphoma uh this was published last
year uh with cr rates of uh about 80 percent 81 percent with the 2000 milligrams pre-treatment
with obinutuzumab and higher rates of crs and icans in mantle cell compared to what we see in
dlbcl
improved with the 2000 milligram pre-treatment however despite the high response rates the
duration of complete response is uh fairly limited um with a median duration of complete response of
15 months so there's uh potentially room for improvement uh there is increasing recognition of
uh the micro environment uh contributing to the progression and potentially therapy resistance
in mantle cell lymphoma this has been better studied in dlbcl but also in mantle cell
particularly these cd163 positive macrophages which potentially which can support tumor growth
through baff and other factors as well as presence of immuno suppressed microenvironment which may
confer resistance to immunotherapies again better characterized in dlbcl than mantle cell
and there is some evidence that btk inhibitors can have immunomodulatory functions
these are just a couple of examples that first the top two are
btk inhibitors and btk inhibitors and btk inhibitors and btk inhibitors this is a study from antonin
papin a few several years ago looking at prior to ibrutinib and post ibrutinib decreases in il-10 and
cd-163 positive macrophages and the bottom is from cll actually uh looking at uh by specific
antibodies a cd-19 directed by specific antibody uh in btki naive or exposed patients and uh there
there was increased cell killing among uh the btki uh exposed patients
uh that was including with a calibrutinib so maybe independent of the off-target effects of
ibrutinib on itk so that's led to the rationale for this study which is that the combination of
pyrtobrutinib and glofitamab will be safe and effective in a relapsed refractory mantle cell
lymphoma and this is the study design it's a multi-center single arm phase 2 study a fixed
duration Glofitamab and mrd guided pyrtobrutinib so in cohort 1 the safety lead-in cohort of six
patients which is finished enrolling uh patients uh get obinutuzumab two doses a thousand milligrams
on day one and day two Glofitamab standard step-up dosing um although with uh intensified steroids
dexamethasone the day before day of and day after for the step-up doses and also infused
over eight hours instead of four hours due to the higher crs risk and then pyrtobrutinib starts
in cycle two day eight and is continued uh until patients achieve mrd negativity by
nocic which we know is prognostic and mantle cell based on echo and other trials so patients get pet
scans after every four cycles they get an mrd assay at the end of cycle 12. if they are mrd
negative they can stop pyrtobrutinib at that time otherwise it continues and mrd is rechecked every
six cycles right now we have enrolled the first six patients we're currently collecting the data
for the safety uh review before opening cohort two which is the expansion uh in which pyrtobrutinib
may start in day one uh or maintain a day cycle two day eight depending on our data
our objectives again are safety and tolerability in the first six patients and preliminary activity
for our primary uh objectives uh secondary or standard uh other um activity uh metrics as well
as undetectable mrd rate kinetics of mrd as well as treatment free interval and then safety and
tolerability in the entire cohort and then we have a number of exploratory endpoints
including aminophenotyping next generation sequencing we're also collecting early time
points for subsequent mrd assays to see if patients achieve early mrd and then also quality of life
during and after study treatment eligibility criteria so adult patients with mcl previously
treated we're including patients who discontinued a covalent btk inhibitor due to intolerance or who
completed a fixed duration therapy and subsequently relapsed but not patients who progressed on a
covalent btk inhibitor and then other standard inclusion criteria so again very early days only
six patients enrolled but we're doing the interim analysis now and gathering the data what i can
show so far from these six patients so all white male patients so far all stage four mostly low risk
simplified mipi however uh three of six had blastoid or pleomorphic and four of six had uh
high ki67 none of the patients had tp53 aberrancy
uh very limited ae data so um the uh grade three four aes uh were all neutropenia um grade uh
five uh sorry no grade five aes
aes were all crs during the step-up dosing leading to prolongation of hospitalization
um you can see on the top right uh we saw a um we saw um grade two crs and grade two icans in one
patient uh grade one crs and grade uh in two patients grade one icans in one patient uh and
then at the bottom right uh again full data only for four of the six patients but uh what really
stands out is three of the patients had grade three or higher neutropenia which responded well to
growth factors and no episodes of febrile neutropenia um one episode of uh grade one
infection and this is the preliminary activity so uh several patients have not had their first
three of the patients have not had their first response assessment uh one patient has had a cr
and is still on treatment two patients have gotten to the end of cycle 12 have undetectable mrd and
have discontinued therapy and are in follow-up so we anticipate that the combination will be safe
and effective we're still waiting for more data still very early days and uh hopefully this will
emerge as an appropriate mrd guided strategy thank you